now imagine if the Democratic Party of
let's say Georgia had sponsored a voter
registration drive with balloons and
posters you know they'd have a sign-up
station it'd be manned by eager party
volunteers on the sidewalk let's say
outside of shopping mall then a van
pulls up and a driver rolls down the
window but then he hits the gas and he
plows through the tent luckily luckily
no injuries well this story of course
would lead every major newscast and
regardless of the facts Trump hating
reporters would jump to the conclusion
that he was at least partly the impetus
for such a heinous act well on Saturday
27 year-old Gregory Tim was arrested in
Jacksonville Florida for plowing into a
Republican get-out-the-vote tent outside
a Walmart the GOP of Duval County said
that six volunteers were targeted
now this assailant wasn't registered to
vote he didn't have much of a social
media presence and the Duval County
Democrats released a statement saying
we're thankful that the perpetrator of
this cowardly act has been apprehended
by police and continue to call for
civility during this election cycle well
good for them for condemning but that
sentiment wouldn't have been enough had
the shoe been on the other foot now it's
important to note that there has
essentially been no response from the
Democrat 2020 candidates about this who
claim to care so deeply about such
issues need a 21st century Voting Rights
Act so the kind of voter suppression
we've seen cannot stand we need to
repeal every one of the voter
suppression laws that is out there right
cowardly Republican governors are trying
to suppress the vote that is an
incredibly undemocratic unamerican
process voter suppression voter
intimidation it matters to the Democrats
do you think that's pretty intimidating
when a van drives through a registration
tent now I guess it's possible but my
opinion highly unlikely that anti-trump
rage wasn't at least part of the
motivation here we'll find more out more
as the days go on but predictably
the media has barely covered this story
at all think about this the attack
happened on Saturday and as of Sunday
morning only NBC Sunday today covered it
and only for 25 seconds now remember
what preceded this Florida attack think
about the dark and sinister way
prominent people are talking about the
president the outcome of his impeachment
trial and America in general once
fascists get power they don't give it up
you've got president from for life
unless it is president-elect as a
legitimate president there is no
exoneration no vindication no real
acquittal from a fake trial we have a
racist society from top to bottom this
may have started as an anti-trump
movement but in some quarters you just
saw it it's become an anti America
movement face it Trump's policies
they're largely working and at least
half of America supports them so I have
a question are they all illegitimate 262
million people voted for him last time
around or they just the deplorable
Hillary described or they just stupid or
are they just racist this whole thing is
getting out of hand and it smacks of
total desperation on the part of the
Democrats now we still don't know which
and Tifa thugs are responsible for
citizen journalists sandino's brain
bleed last year of the Democrats running
for president at the time only
drue Yang and Joe Biden even condemned
that attack political leadership in
cities such as Portland Oregon Berkeley
you've seen this kind of craziness a lot
on the Left Coast where the rampage took
place they've largely turned a blind eye
to leftist violence police are given
stand-down orders and mast and Tifa
radicals have been allowed to wail on
anyone who gets in their way with
impunity
especially Trump supporters no
consequences few if any arrests and
these people claim Trump's the ones
stoking hatred are you kidding me the
nonstop most cruel demonization of the
President and anyone who works for him
or supports him occurs 24/7 and it's not
just by knit cap wearing basement
dwellers on social media this is
happening at the hands of supposedly
respected members of the media and the
political establishment let me be very
clear you're stupid as hell you're one
of those people I say should not be
allowed around household appliances you
will take off some fingers if not your
entire hand the obvious misogynist and
the obvious vulgarity there'll be
stupidity he's not mentally okay
[Music]
and the category of the people who think
he's racist now these are the same
people who claim to be so woke so
compassionate so tolerant but for them
the ends ridding us of Trump of course
always justifies the means
now remember the mock assassination of
Trump during that Shakespeare in the
Park
it's an actor dressed to look just like
President Donald Trump as he's
assassinated on stage look as his
character is stabbed to death and
there's no mistaking that Trump
connection Trump had only been in office
for a couple of years or a couple of
months excuse me mark Kathy Griffin
holding up the president severed head or
NBA stars and coaches who've been bought
off by China but feel morally superior
when trashing Trump I've never been more
angry and disgusted at this situation
that I am now our country's an
embarrassment in the world the number
one job in America the point of person
is someone who doesn't understand the
people and really don't good by the
people or the vicious anti Cavanagh
protests they're still trying to get in
the Supreme Court by the way they kept
banging no one answer and of course
there's our favorite Robert foreveryoung
De Niro is the president the guy is a
fool come on this guy is like a
gangster's a con artist
he talks how he wants to punch people in
the face the man just needs better lines
come on Bobby
now while Democrats blamed Trump himself
for creating an atmosphere of fury and
racism the president with smart policies
has done more to help the black
community than any president in the
modern era it's the Democrats and their
most radical elements who are fostering
a toxic and dangerous atmosphere now
it's not enough just to disagree with
president Trump's policies
they try day in and day out to destroy
him and his family
but they failed their viciousness isn't
just directed though at president Trump
left-wing activists are turning to
attacking police now - during
impeachment the chaos at New York's
Grand Central Station carried out by
antifa and Occupy Wall Street it didn't
get the coverage it deserved what a
disgrace
the protesters are so courageous in
their masks by the way cowards every
last one of them they'd be the first
ones to wet their pants if they really
needed a police officer an emergency the
day anything ever happened to those
people though they disrupted transit one
of the busiest train stations in the
United States but this wasn't even about
wanting free stuff they were testing de
Blasio and Cuomo so will there be any
repercussions for this of course not
there never is de Blasio is hated by the
police for good reason he doesn't have
their backs and they know it this has
created a poisonous and frankly it's
created a dangerous dynamic for the
people of this city and it's not gonna
end until once again they elect someone
like Rudy Giuliani who was tough but
fair and things are now even worse and
YPD officers were targeted in two
separate assassination attempts this
past weekend the police unions say de
Blasio's rhetoric is to blame bad people
on the streets are listening and coming
after us
the first thing I thought when I got
this call another cop in the 4-1 was
shot 12 hours later I said they're
hunting us they're hunting us this is an
intolerable disgrace they sow violence
and then they demonize the police the
only thing standing between us and them
the police in an economy when so many
are benefiting the Democrats should see
that all of this rage it's not really
getting much traction with regular
America
after a while you keep raging and you
just look impotent and that's the angle